Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now, I've gotten new names to put on the locker here, and, uh, some of them are good ideas, some of them are bad ideas.
Starting off with *Bulla Breif* said: "Actually, Mark, there's a rumor that you can tame a Reaper Leviathan. Just imagine it: swimming around with one of those terrifying things on your side!"
I don't think that's true. I don't care how many peepers I feed it. *(laughs)* I just don't think it's true! XD
Uh, also, *Adam Wolf* has said, uh, "There's supposed to be a pet you can get called the cuddlefish, it says their eggs are located in the lost river laboratory deep, Grand Reef Degassi, sea base dunes, and sinkhole mushroom forest."
I will, uh, eventually go find that. I don't know if I'll be able to do that this episode, because I kinda wanna get the hatching enzymes and get that outta there,
and then I wanna start on the other thing, but, I will get to that eventually.
And then, finally, jack *SinofSloth* who said: "If you travel to the deadzone (the edge of the map of Subnautica), you will find the adult Ghost Leviathan and probably your (Mark Screws it up again) untimely demise. Just a heads up, if you manage to travel 8,000 meters down, you'll be teleported back to life pod 5. (Not)
Well, thank you very much for that. And, I don't like the implication that there is an ADULT ghost leviathan because I've already encountered the ghost leviathan, illegitimately, I suppose,
but I encountered the ghost leviathan... I don't want to encounter the ADULT ghost leviathan. But that's exactly what I'm gonna do, so everybody
buhUHUHUUUUH...everybody buckle (Something that sounds like a voice crack) up!
It's gonna be a BuMpY RiDe!
I'mma-I'mma take some peepers with me just in case
Okay, so here's the thing: I'm gonna go, sheerly by the, the, the skinny skin on my, my skinny skin (what?)
I'm gonna go...and I'm just gonna schwim!
I'm just gonna swim
All the way
until I reach the quote on quote "Dead Zone"...
Now I'm pretty much in the center of the map, so this is gonna take a bit, but everybody just hold on! Hold on to your hats...
I just pissed myself. (oh great)
Cause I'm gonna go...to the edge of the map...and see how true this is...
and I don't know if a peeper's gonna help...but I got one!
Alright...
Here we go
Oh, man I'm far out.
Oh, MAN I'm far!
Oh MAN
Okay....
I'm very far.
I see a *pheph* HI, Boomerang! What're you doin- what're YOU doing out here?!
Ooo
Oh, there's a Peeper. There's another Peeper. Okay...
Well, least I know I got Peepers out here.
Oh... I hate this. I hate this.
EHUUHHHUH
HUHHH
I HATE this.
EHUUHHHUH
YEEe
At least it's not NIGHT.
*Karen-Warning entering ecological dead zone. Adding report to data bank*
wha-?
huH?
aaAh
EUUGGHH
(goodbye Mark)
WOOAHHH!! AHHH!! AHHH!!
PEEPER!!
OH my GOD!!!!
OOHHHhhh GOD
I HAVE A PEEPER FOR YOU
I am go~ING
OH my GOD!!!!
OH MY GOD!!
OWWWWWIIIIEEEEE!! :(
HOLY SHIT!!
OH that was TERRIFYING-(insert bitchbaby scream) OOOOOOOHHHHHHHHH
RUN AWAY!!!
*groans*
Oh my god.... AHHH!!
Okay, Well there I go *(laughs sadly)*
*continues to laugh sadly*
ah..
Alright...
Well, got some fresh piss outta that. Thats... something nice
What's the uh *laughter*
What's the uh
what's the uh
Ecological "Dead Zone" all about? Here we go, Crater's Edge.
"The geological scans of this area show a steep decline in all directions. This data is consistent with the theory that the Aurora
crashed on the edge of a 2km x 2km volcanic crater it has likely been millenia since an eruption reached the surface, encouraging the ecosystem within the crater to flourish.
The ecology of the trench surrounding the crater supports only two life:
microscopic *(laughs)* and leviathon class.*(laughs again)*
Alrighty then,
Exploration is ill advised *Laughs at his choice to explore anyway*
Wow That's convenient
*groans*
Alright
Okay- Anyway
Glad we did that
I'm really glad, I'm really realy glad
Well now that that's all said and done
And we have finished being stupid (Who Mark? never!)
Now we can get on with the rest of the thing
that we need. Now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go for the hatching enzyme samples
Right now Im gonna take
Bubblegum on a maiden voyage here and we're
gonna go find these places. Now we can't
go too deep which means that I don't
think that we can get all of these until
we upgrade the the uh- the diving module to
like MK 3 at least or MK 2 at least but
we're gonna do what we can. Okay I just
gave- ahh I pissed myself but I just gave
Bubblegum here a storage module so that
I can have a little extra storage on my
way. Now the first place we're gonna go
to is the bulb zone which has two of the
ingredients that we need for the the
hatching enzymes, Ah Karen I missed you I
missed you baby and I know that you
greeted me before in this particular
seamoth but
you know I was a little aggressive dude
because I was still mourning the loss.
Now I've completely forgotten about the
old seamoth and I'm all about Bubblegum -as are we all
Hey can I get a stalker tooth from you?
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna need an enameled glass
HEY! BITE MY ASS! BITE IT! BITE MY ASS! BITE MY ASS! *mumbles* you didn't bite my-BITE MY ASS
hey what are you doing? BITE MY ASS!! wait wait dude
dude come on I'm inviting you I'm
inviting you to bite my ass-all right
that didn't work but then again that
never works and I don't know why but it
never ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever works when I want it to work so
we're gonna carry on as if nothing
happened and we're gonna get these
goddamn samples. One of these is very
easy eugh look at this. Why do I always gotta go out at night. I see I could get
three of them actually because I think
one of them is just this uhh this mushroom
sample I'm pretty sure you just need a
piece of this bad boi and if I get a
piece of diss, you better not be a reaper, yeah yeah yeah- where'd you go whoa
Bubblegum Bubblegum you watch you you
watch yourself around here I ain't gonna
let a Reaper get you again-not that it
got you before I'm kind of projecting my
old failures upon myself right now
and applying them to you but that
doesn't matter. Heeeyyy, Hi how's it going? who's there better not be
anybody important-the second thing is
one of deze bad bois right here! This is
all I need so eueehh okay I think that's it.
Alright hey hey hey
Who be zappy? you no zappy me! Alright hang
on.. OH why am i out?!? why AM I OUT?!? eeehee!! okay alright-we're fine okay so the other thing is a
very rare one and I believe it's in this
zone but it's just VERY rare it's the
Sea-crown I've found it before but-ohhh
okay, great, it's the sea crown and I need
to find it again. That's not it it's
there. Oww-hey! OWWW! My ass!! Can you not smack dat ass??
If a goddamn Reaper Leviathan decides to
be a sneaky peeky get me out of
nooooo~where I'm gonna be, HOW DID THAT HURT ME? HOW DID THAT HURT ME?!?
Son of a tit! oh... it's awfully it casplodey around here. God it's just a
heart-pounding thing being, like why is
it like perpetual darkness over here too - why
can't it be some sort of lightness?? You
know? Happy fun times down under da sea (because it's not the Little Mermaid Mark)
heyyyehhe, under da sea, uhh, why's everything gotta be
terrible all the time? Oh that's not good
*delayed reaction*  OW-OH-HEY! WOAH! OH OH OH REPAIRING!! REPAIRING!! *sudden accent* REPAIRING!
AANNDDD we outtie(x5)
Oh my god Oh my gooooood(x3) uohhh gooood,
Oh hey Sea Bottom Dweller! How are you doing? Good to see you again
Aright
whoo-kay pissed myself, great. HEY HEY HEY WOAH! WOAH! WOAH! WAIT HANG ON a SeCoNd- uhh I think
that I'll that's that's it isn't it god
damn it oh well of course it is okay oh
that was hard to find all right okay it
was impossible I couldn't have seen that
from a distance how is that even fair
okay whatever is fine I'm almost dead
that was absurdly difficult I don't know
I took so long I gotta get back to my
bait all right die but at least I got it
so I got our got like three no I got too
many of those I've got three of the food
okay all right I'm out I'm out I get it
I'm not welcome here I get it I get it I
get it I get it
all right I'm now welcome here but I got
three of the five which is good and
there's only two left and then I can
make hatching enzymes and then I'm good
to go I'm good to goooo
ah hate hate to just hate all right
anyway so the other two are exactly
shave before I mysteriously died in a
horrible way that was an ordeal already
but the other one the iStock I believe
it's in the I believe it's in the
underwater caves but I'm not 100% sure
about that I mean I'll fight it find out
soon enough but not terribly worried
about it that ordeal thankfully is a
little bit over not a hundred percent
over but just a little bit over I'm
gonna dock this real quick and big box
berry here long PD wonky okay yeah
thanks Kevin
all right whatever your name is I don't
even remember let's get some potatoes
oh god I've got too many secrets do I
even need these do I have indeed these
for anything because I could grow more
if I really wanted to do but I don't
really I'm gonna put you in the
punishment one boat oh okay
I'm good yeah that was an ordeal I don't
know why that one's always an ordeal but
it was an ordeal all right well these
are oh no these are good gonna gimme
gimme
okay ah he won replant the other
easy-peasy
Boop and okay my potatoes growing don't
want these to wash down I'm good to go
all right I'm good to go huh it's sorry
I'm just a little stressed okay so I've
got those you are so close so close
you're a big one oh you're a big one
okay so oh all right
let me think about what I need to do so
I gotta find well I'm gonna find one
more of these bad boys I'm gonna find
one more of these bad boys I'm gonna
find one more of these bad boys
and then I'm gonna try to get one from
the let's see if I can close out like
let's see if I can get all five I'm
pretty sure I can it's just not 100%
sure if I can by I'm pretty sure I can
only go on the adventure
Fushimi repair me first okay don't drift
away from me that's gone now that we're
a little less dead I'd be lovely so I
need to go to a kelp cave to get the ice
talk and then the blood kelp
I can probably swim down on my own alone
which I don't want to do but I can do it
what the hell Oh some black mossy fish
so pancha swim bladders oh he don't look
so good
all right but I'm gonna go get these if
I don't get them then that's fine if I
do get them then I'm dead weight no
backwards that's not the way uh-huh
ah now that is a blood kelp zone and I
don't want to go I don't want to go down
there by hand but I think that's the
only thing that I can do at the moment
and I'm pretty sure the ghost weed is
gonna be down there so time to stop
being a wait is it up here maybe there's
a ghost weed up here and I don't have to
go down there don't look like it I guess
I'm going down whoo-hoo-hoo yes that is
you I don't have to go down by myself
yes yes yes II
yes your baby all right sorry
there we go I don't know I had to do
that sound but you know it is what it is
I do need these four for polyaniline so
I'm gonna get as many deep shrooms as I
can stuff my pockets full of shroom all
right I'm Audi I just need one more
which is a nice stock and I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure that gotta be from
like the deep caves and not these things
so I've got shoes and I've got
everything and then I've got extra
storage and Bubblegum before anything
else that I could possibly need but I'm
doing good I can get the last one yeah
I'm an accomplished person on the oven
accomplished human being that does tasks
and executes them I have plans and then
I do plans yeah haha okay I'm getting
near where am I actually let me get a
bearing I
it also says it's in the crag fields
which I believe yeah they're just on the
ass end of the aurora maybe near Reaper
territory I don't know but I'm getting
close to it so if it's in the Krag field
then it should be a lot easier to find
than in some anonymous cave in the kelp
zone but I'm just gonna keep my peepers
peeled well that looks craggy is this
the crag field yeah this is it you okay
yeah all right oh okay yeah I believe
you
okay crag field all right let's see if
you've got some eye stocks because
that's what I need right now
that's a thorny bush where's the highest
stalk
thorny bushes oh there we go
don't hit me thorny bouche I got you no
no no no no no I will not be swayed I
will not be swayed I will not be swayed
you hypnotic bastard okay I got all of
them yeah oh let's see if I can get back
home safe without running in anything
devious ah home sweet home okay all
right okay
not so bad not so bad at all this is
going rather well all right I got my
hunt for the materials that I noted now
I just gotta settle my score with the
Emperor and I don't know why I said it
so ominously but I got everything I need
and that should allow me to do what I
need to do I have everything in bubble
butt over there I'll plug transfer it
over to big box Barry to actually make
the trip because I'm pretty sure that
the depth required and the sea emperor's
cave is not good enough for little ol
Bubblegum over there plus I want to
protect Bubblegum and I don't want
Bubblegum to die so thank you everybody
so much for watching in the next episode
I will cure myself and get started on
building the rocket pad so that we can
get off of this rock once and for all
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know your thoughts down
in the comments below now bit my lip and
as always I will see you in the next
video